Welcome.
It's awesome to
see everyone here.
This is the third
and final event
sponsored by the McDermott
Award for Arts at MIT.
My name's Meejin Yoon,
I'm head of the Department
of Architecture.
I'd like to welcome everyone
across the auditorium
this evening.
I'd like to make a
special thanks, of course,
to the Council for Arts at
MIT for sponsoring the award
and arts at MIT for organizing
all these amazing panels
and residency events
throughout this year.
This semester, we've
been talking a lot
about the future,
multiple futures.
The future of the library,
the future of campus,
and today, the
future of the museum.
For MIT, these topics
are not abstract musings
about possible things to come
but really timely, critical,
and defining as we literally
reimagine and reinvent
our library, our
campus, and our museum
today for the immediate future.
While the term future
is arguably overused,
I would like to use
this opportunity
to actually unpack
and open up this term.
Beyond a speculative open ended
and positivist projection,
I think the term
actually allows us
to probe deeper into our
cultural questions and values
today.
In the words of science fiction
novelist, William Gibson,
the future is already here.
It's just unevenly distributed.
[LAUGHTER]
In looking for this unevenly
distributed present feature,
we have assembled
an esteemed group
of museum directors,
architects, and artists
to give us a perspective on
the contemporary issues facing
the museum and what is at stake
for the future of culture.
The museum is not just a
building but, of course,
an institution.
As institutions, museums
are collections, archives,
think tanks, agents and they
can tell stories, provoke,
or canonize.
They are both cultural
condensers and catalysts.
We know very well the recent
museum boom, the Bilbao effect,
launched an intense worldwide
museum-building campaign,
with museums as stand-ins or
indicators of cultural maturity
or arrival.
How can they be
not only indicators
of cultural maturity,
but actually catalysts
for both cultural and
social change, both inside
and outside the museum walls?
How can architecture play a role
as a mediator between artists,
institution, and public?
Between the institution
and the city?
And between the
collections and its public?
Amongst the speakers, there are
a number of incredible projects
completed or underway, which
speak to these questions
and the limits and possibilities
of futures as institutions that
intersect and transform
the way we operate
and curate our world.
Our speakers need
no introduction
and so I have
abbreviated their bios
so that we can hear from them
directly as soon as possible.
Our first speaker
will be David Adjaye.
David Adjaye, you know well.
He's spoken to us many times
throughout the semester.
He's the recipient of
the 2016 McDermott Award
for Arts at MIT.
He's an internationally
celebrated architect.
His recently completed
works, including
libraries in Washington, DC, the
SKOLKOVO School of Management
in Moscow, and the Museum of
Contemporary Art in Denver.
Adjaye Associates
is currently working
on projects in Rwanda,
Ganda, India, London,
Lebanon, and New York City.
Yesterday, he and Zena Howard of
Perkins and Will Freelon Group
discussed their soon
to open, eagerly
anticipated Smithsonian
National Museum
of African-American History
and Culture with our students.
The museum will open very
soon, shortly this fall.
He has, in his last
lecture, shared with us
how architects play a role in
storytelling and institution
building.
Thelma Golden is the
director and chief
curator of the Studio
Museum in Harlem,
an art museum founded in 1968.
His mission is to serve
as the nexus of artists
of African descent
locally, nationally,
and internationally.
Under her leadership, the museum
has gained increasing renown
as a center for
contemporary art,
innovative education, and a
site for diverse audiences.
Golden was previously a
curator at the Whitney Museum,
where she organized numerous
groundbreaking exhibitions,
including the 1994 Black Male
Representations of Masculinity
in American Art.
Thelma Golden has referred
to the museum as a think
tank and exhibitions
as a white paper,
with the idea that museums
could forecast a wiser
and more inclusive society.
Charles Renfro is partner at
Diller Scofidio + Renfro, also
a renowned interdisciplinary
design studio and architecture
firm.
Diller Scofidio is the recipient
of the 1999 McDermott Award
here that MIT.
Charles' early projects
include the Institute
of Contemporary
Art here in Boston,
the Blur Building in
Switzerland, the Brown Creative
Arts Center, and the
Juilliard in New York.
He's currently building
major museums, libraries,
and institutions in
China, Russia, and Brazil.
DSR's current proposal for
the culture shed in New York
demonstrates that architects
can be proactive instigators,
establishing program
and institution
building by rethinking
relationships of organization
and curatorial freedom.
Jill Medvedow is the Ellen
Matilda Pos' director
of the Institute of Contemporary
Art here in Boston since 1998.
As director, she built the
first new art museum in Boston
in nearly a century.
Under her direction, the
ICA expanded its exhibitions
and performance program.
It became a collections,
a collecting institution
and has become a national
leader in arts education.
The ICA's recent exhibit,
Leap Before You Look--
Black Mountain
College 1933 to '57,
exemplifies the
ICA's integration
of exhibition, performance,
and community engagement.
Lorna Simpson is a
well-known conceptual artist
from Brooklyn, New York.
She's known for her
large scale photography
and text-based works,
videos, and drawings
that confront and challenge the
conventional views of gender
identity, culture,
history, and memory.
Her work has been exhibited
at the Museum of Modern Art,
the Museum of Contemporary
Art in Chicago,
the Walker Art Center
in Minneapolis, as well
as Documenta11, and the
56th Venice Biennale.
Last, I'm going to
introduce Timothy Hyde, who
is an associate professor
of architecture history
here at MIT.
His research focuses
on the intersection
of architecture and politics.
He is the author of
Constitutional Modernism--
Architecture and
Civil Society in Cuba
and is the chair of the
Aggregate Architectural History
Collaborative.
That is our esteemed
panel and I'd
like to first welcome David up
to share with us his thoughts.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
It's great to be
back in this room,
having these conversations.
I'm not going to make
any grand statements yet,
I think that we're going
to leave that till the end.
But I want to take you
through a series of projects
to ask a series of
questions and to maybe show
a series of
trajectories that are
happening at the beginning of
this millennia, this century.
I'm going to go
from small to things
that are also on
the board to things
that are just completing.
I want to start with
this project, which
is called Rivington Place.
It's a project that
was completed in 2007.
It's an important project
for me because in a way,
it was about the--
what I would call the guerilla
work of a profound educator,
intellectual teacher, author,
Stuart Hall, who took it
upon himself to really talk
about the lack of scholarship
and archive around the
Black contribution to Europe
and the influence
of the Caribbean,
et cetera, in the arts discourse
in Europe, specifically.
It really was a kind
of a guerilla operation
for many decades, before the
Arts Council, a body in the UK
finally recognized that this was
an important institution that
had created a new
body of work that
needed its own institution.
They were given a
grant and a commission
to finally set up a
base for the archive
but also to create a dissolved
hybrid institution, which
is between the archive,
the library, the community
space, the education
space, the workspace.
The site that were
given was placed
in this very historic
part of London and Hoxton,
but in the 17th century
and 18th century Hoxton.
This idea of a new body
within this context
was a fascinating proposition.
Of course, I'm not talking
about it as a lecture
but just to give you a clue,
I think this section gives you
the clue of the diversity of the
types that I'm talking about.
Everything from
acknowledging also
the industrial heritage
of the area, which
is next to the
Georgian heritage,
and the different
programmatic functions that
are in the building
in terms of education,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
This building is a hybrid
that's working within this very
particular historical
context and uses
computational technology.
It uses the idea of being
able to create a system where
there's a relationship that's
been made with this context
but also there's another
discourse happening.
What you're looking at is
an image which is actually
about a foreshortened view.
The grid is not equal.
It expands from 2
feet to 15 feet.
The idea was to look at this
idea of optics and perception
as a way to make a building.
This is the building looking
as though it is a set up.
It's this idea of an institution
that's in this context
but is questioning and
asking about the context
and talking about the
nature of the condition.
In its very general sense,
it's a very large window,
which you see at the base, and
that really becomes a window
directly onto the streets.
A shopfront of
exhibitions and galleries,
which is then a space for
white or black space projects.
Education and screening rooms,
small, very small screening
rooms and exhibition spaces.
The archive, which
is in the heart
of the plan, which has
the biggest archive
and has become the place
where documentation
about the activities of
the diaspora in Europe
and the Caribbean is stored.
And has become a very important
academic resource in London.
Then there's obviously
the office areas
and the way in which the
building distributes itself.
The studios that are up above
for like-minded institutions,
which are part of the mix
of the life of the building.
I'll move to something
more familiar.
This is a project
in Denver, which
is to make a type
of ICA institution.
Those of you who--
Is this working?
Is this gone?
OK, fine.
[CHUCKLES]
The ICA is a museum of
contemporary art in Denver.
The thinking with the
board and the director
at the time, Sydney
Payton, was to think
about the notion of the
contemporary art space
not as a flexible
large container
but the exact opposite.
To return back to the
practice of artists
and to look at the scales
of practice and production
and to see if that could
be somehow constructionally
narrated into a scenario
where instead of flexibility,
you had a fixed set of
proportions and geometries,
which would allow a
diversity of art practice
to flourish within
it without worrying
about the reconfiguring.
The research was all about
how to look at different art
practices and different
spaces that artists work
in from their apartments
through to factories,
through to institutional
spaces, and to configure
a series of volumes that are
stacked, almost in a very
classical way with a
cellar, a middle, and a top,
to create a house that in its
nature, is a house which is,
in a way, distributed almost
like a little mini art
collage, art city collage.
The building is basically
in a downtown area,
which was a very
brick-dominated architecture.
The idea was to--
It does two things.
It was the first
[INAUDIBLE] building
in this country for the arts.
But it was also about making
a diffuse building, which
created a neutral plane.
The reason was that, in a way,
the downtown area was emerging
as a new camp, a new area
that was to be rebuilt.
The building wanted
to create a restraint
frame against the new commercial
and residential high density,
which is happening.
And now it's happened.
If you're in Denver,
you can see it.
When it was made, it was
a very isolated element.
Now, with the context of the
hyper commercial architecture,
it becomes a restraint and
entropy within this condition.
The building is expressed,
the geometry and the volumes
are expressed, and the
qualities of light in Denver--
That image at the front,
Denver's about a mile high.
--is also enjoyed.
The geography and the
atmosphere and the environment
of that place is enjoyed.
Then you have different
scales of spaces
where spaces where windows
bring in indirect light
with different proportions.
Where skylights reflect light
down into halo chambers.
Where you have relationships
to the city that
are curated to create diaphanous
spaces which are diffuse,
where the chambers in
these sort of spaces
create almost a medieval
compressed city for events
looking through
the entire section
and program of the building.
Where you have
education spaces which
differentiate their
quality and create
destinations for the community.
Education spaces that
are journeys at the top
of the building, which
also talk about the city.
Extraordinary
gallery spaces that
are 30 feet high that talk
about the scale of sculpture
and the condition
of contemporary art
in terms of scales,
large and small forms.
Then respite, the
notion of just a place
to be in the city to enjoy
one's location and one's place
and to reflect.
This is a project
I'm working on now.
We're not allowed to
show too many pictures.
This is the Studio Museum,
it's a work in progress.
But the Studio Museum,
if you don't know,
it is a very
important institution
that obviously was just
described just a second ago.
But the idea that this
institution, which
in its essence essentially
is the radicality and Thelma
Golden has talked about
it being the think
tank, but the radicalities.
This is one of the
few institutions which
permeates the artist as a very
constant, live scenario that
is continually questioning and
in dialogue with institution.
The Studio Museum
literally is a space
of studios for artists to
be present in the building.
And to interact with the
curators and the public
and to make works which
are celebrated yearly.
The building is also a testimony
about a certain engagement
with the context
of Harlem and how
that engagement with that
public is to be programmed
and in that porosity,
to be enjoyed.
What you're looking at is,
really, a sectional study.
I like using these
sectional studies
to talk about the notions,
the scales of the civic,
the public, the art spaces,
the compressed education
spaces, and the
archive and offices,
et cetera, that are held
within the building.
This notion of a building which
dissolves at its ground plain
but also expresses the
studio and education
elements as
programmatic typologies,
which are stacked on
top of each other,
is really the agenda behind it.
Also, we're hoping that as
the building sets itself up,
it creates an entropy because
Harlem has been re-zoned
and it's going through
a radical rebuilding.
That the building
also can maybe become
a figure that sets a certain
cultural permanence and entropy
within the flux context of 125th
Street, which the location is.
Then lastly, the
Smithsonian, which
I've shown before but
I just will quickly
go through with you, which
is on the Washington Mall.
Really is a 200-year struggle
to place a narrative museum
on the heart of the
nation's monumental core.
One which would celebrate the
narrative of the contribution
of the African-American
community
to the identity of America.
Really, the building is this
lens to understand that.
This idea that finally, at
the beginning of 21st century,
it's very clear that this
notion of the narrative
and understanding
the cosmopolitan
condition of our urban
cities as we identify
and the complexity of the matrix
of people that come together
to create the Metropolitan,
requires a kind of unfolding
of the story, of all
the constitutions, all
the constituents of the
parts to create a richer
dialogue and more tolerance.
I think in a way,
a healthy relation
in terms of understanding
origins and sources.
The building is a museum, yes,
but it's a narrative museum.
It's not a fragment of a story.
It's not about a trauma
but it is about an entire
picking a moment for that
journey to have begun to now.
It really is a building
which is in three parts.
It talks about history, then
it talks about the present,
and it talks about
looking to the future.
This tripartite nature is imbued
in the nature of the building.
The project attempts to
create not just a container
for the work but the building
whose very silhouette
and materiality derives
from the context
of the narrative of the story.
But also of the
condition of Washington
in that monumental
position, the core.
This is the building here.
Then this is the building
as it's finishing.
And how it's going to work.
Ta-da.
[LAUGHTER]
Done.
There you go.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
That was great.
Thank you.
OK, good.
That was great.
Thelma?
No?
Charles?
Don't start the timer
until I tell you to.
I'm going to get
through 20 slides first.
I have 105 slides so--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to do this quickly.
I'm going to start my timer now.
What makes a museum?
I thought we'd start
with the questions
because I've got 120 slides and
if I don't get to the pictures,
at least you can have some
things to think about.
Objects, performance, events,
restaurants, education.
What makes a museum?
Just think about it.
What does the museum do?
Oh, wait.
There's a slide missing.
Uh-oh.
OK, slide was missing.
It was supposed to say educate
enlighten and entertain.
That's what that
was supposed to do.
What makes a museum?
Oh, dear.
My answers are not in here.
What makes a museum?
[LAUGHTER]
How does-- OK, how
does a museum survive?
This is--
[LAUGHTER]
Can I put pause on because
the slides got screwed up.
I didn't even check beforehand.
Boards, the public,
foundations, government.
I mean, look at those
constituent groups.
These are all stakeholders.
However do we make a
museum deal with that?
Who decides content?
Oh, this is good.
They're just straightening up.
Directors, curators,
board members, public.
Everybody who puts money
into a museum has a voice.
How do we listen to and
wrangle those voices together
to make something meaningful?
Who is a museum for?
General public, scholars.
Are museums really
about archiving?
Are they about collections?
Are they about civicness?
These are all questions
that we started
pondering when we were hired
to do the ICA here in Boston.
The ICA had been a roving
institution, housing buildings
that were not made as a museum.
When we were hired
in 2001 to make--
I think, 2001.
We thought, well, what is
a museum building mean?
What's the dichotomy?
What's the duality?
Here you have the
Bilbao effect that I'm
sure we're going to talk
about a lot tonight.
Or do you need something that's
neutral box, like the Goetz
collection by Herzog de Meuron?
We decidedly, along
with our client,
who we worked very, very
closely with, said no.
We're not in that discourse.
We're squarely outside.
But one thing we
felt certain about
is that the site, that beautiful
site on the waterfront,
was nothing but a hindrance.
[LAUGHTER]
For many, many ways.
Many, many reasons.
For one thing, you
couldn't get to it.
It's in a sea of parking lots.
For another thing,
it's gorgeous.
So how does a
museum, which is all
about contemplation, about
looking, about engagement--
how does a museum
take the distractions
and turn them into
something positive?
Our museum is a
machine built to look.
It does so by taking the
site and abstracting it.
I'm sure many of
you have been there.
It does a lot of these things.
It blurs it, it pixelates
it, it edits it down.
Though not as much as we
had originally planned.
Anyway, museums are about
contemplation, often.
The other thing that we
feel very strongly about
is that museums
are civic in nature
and that's something that
they've become more recently.
With the ICA, we were determined
to grow the museum out
of the seeds of the site.
The seeds of the site
are a harbor walk
that was mandated by the
city of Boston, made of wood.
That harbor walk was first
brought into the building
and then brought up
into the building
in the form of a theater.
And a ceiling over
a public space,
which formed a civic base
to a more contemplative top,
housing the art gallery.
Built on a single floor
and reaching all the way
to the water, which required
that we change Boston's newly
instituted zoning plan which
said that you could not
be within 25 feet of the water.
Here's what it looks like.
I hope you've been down there.
The reason that we were able
to convince the city of Boston
to let us build onto
the water's edge
is because we gave
back a donation.
A donation to the city
of Boston in the form
of an outdoor
room, which has now
become one of Boston's most
celebrated outdoor spaces.
A space of extended programming
that the ICA has taken command
of, particularly
in the warm months.
It's become a much
loved and very important
civic space in Boston.
Also a demonstration
project about how
to take the resources
of your community
in and turn them into something
more than what they simply are.
We're very proud of the way that
this building set an example
for other projects in Boston to
actively engage the waterfront.
It's a very, very
simple building,
built on a very simple diagram
of that very harbor wall
coming around and forming
a loop over a theater.
This is actually the
extension of the harbor
walk, the theater.
It was built with
two glass walls.
Those walls are about
bridging between the inside
and the outside, of course,
but also about taking the site
and having the site become a
protagonist in the presentation
of the works, whether they're
visual art or performing art.
Many of the performers
in the theater
have left the blinds
open, though you
can, in fact, dark it down.
Audiences have
gathered on the harbor
walk for free performance.
The building was done
very inexpensively.
Not cheaply but inexpensively.
The theater of
attending the museum
was considered in many ways.
One way was, how do
you get people up
to the top of a building
when all the galleries are
on the top floor?
Well, you do it by making
a piece of spectacle
that, in a way, is
an artwork in itself.
It's an elevator that's
glass and can hold 70 people.
It's a kind of
scanner in itself.
It also controls the
views to and from.
Actually from the museum out
through back of house spaces,
through a coat check room,
through the mediatheque,
to the water, to the
distracting view.
It provides a space that has
been since co-opted by the ICA,
ever interested in finding new
and innovative ways of engaging
the public and showing
art, using the atrium
in front of the elevator.
The galleries themselves,
which sit on the top,
are able to be naturally lit.
They're also able
to be darkened down.
But most importantly,
they're neutral.
I showed two shows
without walls but the room
was intended to be completely
flexible and divisible.
It is right now.
If you go, you'll
see walls throughout.
The hope was that the museum is
constantly reinventing itself.
I think that that's the case.
The programming that
they have put on since we
opened 10,000 years ago--
[LAUGHTER]
--10 years ago has
been spectacular.
Particularly, shows
like Black Mountain,
which simultaneously are
entertaining and educational
and scholarly.
This building is it's,
we think at least,
and you can be the judge
of it and you can quiz us
when we sit down
later, we believe
that it tries to tackle
all of the requirements--
Spectacle, education,
entertainment, all of that.
It does so by
leveraging its site
and bringing its
site in, essentially
as a part of the collection.
The ICA is now a
collecting museum.
Well, guess what they collected?
They collected their site.
Among other things, by the way.
In Los Angeles, kind
of derelict downtown,
Grand Street
redevelopment, which
had started to collect a
lot of cultural jewels,
including the
Music Center, built
in the '60s, about the same
time as Lincoln Center.
And more recently, Frank
Gehry's concert hall.
But it still is a
abandoned place.
It was abandoned forcibly.
In fact, the architecture was
moved, literally forced out
on rollers from Grand
Avenue and the Avenue
was completely reconstructed
as an elevated roadway.
Divorced from the
ground and basically
divorced from the city.
Los Angeles and Los
Angeles' leaders
have been trying to
reconnect Grand Avenue back
to the city for
the three decades,
four decades since they forced
it to be this elevated roadway.
Essentially a freeway
cutting through the middle.
They have leveraged
architecture to bring life back
to downtown and
to a large degree,
they've been quite successful.
If you've been to
Los Angeles, you
know how much downtown
has been changing.
I even walked a few
blocks there recently
and didn't feel endangered.
In fact, I loved it.
But all of this all
of this architecture
is wonderful but it's
also challenging.
It was a challenge when we
were awarded the contract
to do Eli Broad's new private
museum next door to the Disney
Concert Hall in a
very constrained site
with a 70-foot height limit
and a 200-foot street exposure.
We used the opposite approach.
Rather than being shiny
and smooth and sculptural,
we did something flat and
matte and light absorbing.
This is a building that
has a lot of storage in it.
Another issue surrounding
contemporary museums
that have collections,
how do you
account for the ever
increasing amount of things
that you need to have?
We were interested in how
to take those things that
are stored in those dark
spaces and actually leverage
them and turn them into part
of the museum experience.
Our idea was to
enshroud those elements
in a thing we call the vault.
It's sculpted, it's dark,
it's almost Darth Vader-y.
And then pierce it.
There's a lot of
piercing in our projects.
Pierce it with an
escalator right
through the vault that delivers
you to a gallery floor that's
taking the light, the
beautiful Los Angeles light,
through a veil.
That veil is shown here.
The veil is made of
precast concrete.
Each cell of which
faces due North,
and so there's no direct
light into the gallery.
We're very interested
in the cinematic aspect
of getting to the museum,
driving into the museum.
We originally had a
VIP valet drop off
in the lobby of the building.
You drove through the
front door, same front
door that the pedestrians--
Ha-ha --would go through.
The same people that
ticket the pedestrians
drove your car
down to the garage.
We thought that would
be really fantastic.
Eli didn't like that so
much so that was eliminated.
Nonetheless we were
interested in the theater
of getting to the art.
Here is the screen.
We were also interested in
having the screen give glimpses
of the gallery space
and even sometimes art
to Los Angelenos driving
by on Grand Avenue.
Here it is.
In a way, it's a
very mute building
that has been called
the cheese grater
and various other things.
But it's also a very
public building.
It's a free museum.
I think this is
one of the issues
that we need to talk about.
How should we charge to
get people into museums?
I'll tell you a couple of
statistics in the two minutes
and 47 seconds I have left.
You're under the
vault, you enter,
you go up a 100-foot
long escalator one way.
Only one escalator.
You can't even see how
you're going to get out.
It's probably fairly scary.
And you approach art heaven,
essentially in the clouds.
[LAUGHTER]
We made, very much like
the ICA, and riffing
on some of the work
we did here in Boston,
a top lit room
with a partitioning
system that can be brought in.
This 30,000 square foot
space can be broken down
in many, many ways.
This is a part of the first
show that you've seen.
Or you may not, but hopefully
you will get out there.
You can see that
parts of the gallery
are actually glassed in.
You can see that glass
in the very front.
At that moment, you can also
go to the edge of the gallery
and see these fleeting
glimpses of the city pass
by on Grand Avenue below.
When you finally decide
you want to leave,
you can find a stair down.
You can also take this
elevator, glass elevator.
Both of these elements pierce
the vault. That's the elevator
and then here's the stair.
As you wind down a
circuitous stair,
there are several moments
where you can glimpse
into the storage facility.
Here's the reciprocal
view, exchanging
your front of
house spectatorship
to a back of house connoisseur.
You see what's going on.
In fact, there are
thousands and thousands
of works that are there.
They pull the racks
out to show them.
Different works at
different times.
We also worked on the park
next door to the Broad.
In fact, took the
whole side over
and have been trying to
slowly rebuild Grand Avenue.
Giving a model of what
we should be doing down
the Avenue with
landscape and crosswalks
and restaurants and all this
stuff to make it more lively.
You may have heard
that since it opened,
the Broad has received
600,000 visitors.
It's a free museum.
The lines go around the block.
60% of the people
claim to be non-white.
The median income
is $20,000 less
than the median income
in other museums.
This is a survey.
You can ask me the
statistics later.
I'm not exactly sure
where that came from.
But essentially, the freeness
of this museum has exposed--
75% of the people
say they really
have not been exposed
to contemporary art.
That is fairly phenomenal.
That Eli Broad, a person who has
been vilified in Los Angeles--
[ALARM GOES OFF]
I do have three minutes extra.
I'm almost done.
Just two days ago, it was
on Jeopardy as a category.
[LAUGHTER]
Two museums that are underway
with two simple ideas
that we could talk about.
Inclusivity, and it
goes to the point
I just made about the Broad.
How can we take the
haves and have nots?
How can we bring down the museum
so that it's not a barrier?
In Rio de Janeiro, right
on Copacabana beach,
a Democratic surface and
one block away from one
of the most famous favelas,
completely different in nature,
we were commissioned to do
the Museum of Image and Sound,
a museum dedicated
to Brazilian artists.
We wanted to also,
like the ICA, build
this out of the
seeds of the city.
It's a museum about Rio.
We wanted to make it from Rio.
We happened to be on
this beautiful sidewalk
by Burle Marx and we basically
pulled the museum out
of that sidewalk.
That's what it looks like.
The most important
thing about this
is we made it so that
you could walk up
the building, all the way
to a roof, free of charge
without a ticket.
This is the inside
of the museum.
It's an interpretive museum
and a fine art museum,
both at the same time.
That's another thing
we want to think about.
I know Dave has been doing a
lot of interpretive museums,
so have we.
The top is a rooftop cinema,
restaurant, and park.
It's a green space.
No one can get to a
rooftop on Copacabana Beach
unless you're a hotel guest
or a member of a private club.
This is about democracy.
Here it is.
It's under construction,
it's almost finished.
However, the economic downturn--
oh, and there are little--
these cobogó focus your view to
the view of Copacabana Beach,
which is, of course, one of
the most famous beach views
in the world.
Last thing I'm
going to talk about,
and I'll be done in five
slides, flexibility.
What does it mean?
Scale, medium, light, dark,
gray box, white box, black box.
What does that mean these days?
How do we anticipate
the art of the future
and what makes art anyway?
Is it performance?
Is it food?
Is it car design?
We were tasked with thinking
of a new cultural institution.
We call it Culture Shed.
It's a museum that
can change shape.
It's a shape shifter.
It's got a huge
volume that slides out
from over a set of fixed
floored museum quality spaces.
This is 130-foot cube.
It allows all kinds
of programming
to happen simultaneously.
The element that moves out can
be moved out in 15 minutes.
Column-free.
Floor plates can be used
for art exhibition, theater.
Complete flexibility,
completely opposite
of what David was
talking about at Denver.
Here's what it
looks like and it's
going to open in three years.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
That was great.
Oh.
That's great.
Do we wear these?
[LAUGHING]
Lost it.
Thank you.
We decided to--
Change it?
--change it up a little because
the three women thought that
instead of standing up
individually with our responses
to the presentations we had
not yet seen, we would--
[LAUGHING]
--in fact, open up a
conversation as we are
want to do.
That's right.
And respond conversationally.
We unanimously
made that decision.
We did.
[LAUGHING]
There we go.
And here we are.
Jill, do you want to start?
I'll start.
First of all, it's a
great pleasure to be here
and to be part of your
McDermott Award residency.
And to be here, kind
of the hometown girl
so I like that a lot.
It's very interesting and I
have not had this experience
in a really long time, of
hearing one of our architects
talk about our building.
Because I both see it
differently and I certainly
experience it differently and I
didn't design it and then leave
it.
Though we all stayed close.
I actually animated
and activated.
I thought to myself, as a
starting point, that in so much
of your language and your
architectural vocabulary,
you talk a lot
about the piercing
and the disorientation.
It made me remember
specifically why
I think we were such a great--
Why we are such a great pair.
Because you were looking
for that discomfort
and disorientation
and I was looking
for affection and attachment.
[LAUGHTER]
I wanted to build
that into the building
and to make it intimate
and to create a place
that people would come to love.
And that it would be loved by
many different kinds of people
and many different
generations of people.
And that it would be
a place of belonging
in a city that had never had
a place for contemporary art
and contemporary ideas.
That was one of my
first responses is that.
I think that the
beauty of the ICA
comes in fact from
these different pushes
and pulls that we were
able to do together.
I think also that I
thought about very
much the transparency
of our building.
Now, in the seaport around the
ICA, I'm really sick of glass.
I'm not sick of you glass
but the transparency
was something that was both
something that was material,
the materiality of it,
but also philosophically,
we were interested
in the transparency.
It mattered to us
and to the ICA board
tremendously, that when you
walk in, the first thing you see
is our education spaces.
So that our kids
and our families
are seen as one of the core
constituencies in our museum,
alongside with our
public and our donors.
Our teams, which is, to my mind,
the museum of the future to me,
is the teams at the ICA and
the teams at the Studio Museum.
And the team sitting in
this audience tonight,
thank you for coming.
But that they are
in our boardrooms.
There they are with our board.
They are equal to our board
of trustees in the importance
and the vision and the
commitment that they bring.
These are the things
that I was provoked at.
I do think that the questions
that I'm so interested to learn
from are how we talk about this
discourse or this conversation
between the past and
the present, the present
and the future, between
artists and audiences,
between artists and objects.
Again, between
middle aged people
like myself and young people,
between scholars and students.
I keep seeing it as setting up
a possibility of a discourse.
I know I bristle
when we talk about,
as all the architects do,
the wall wants to move.
You had a wall that wanted
to move or a facade.
And you have many walls
that want to move.
But I was like, what do we want?
To basically create
a place for what
could be possible
because none of it's
possible without people.
I know that, this is I think
the last thing I'll say and then
turn it over to
Lorna and Thelma.
But I know for me, when
we built the new museum--
It was a big deal to
build this museum.
It was an against all odds
story in the city that
did not value contemporary
art tremendously
and not collected it in any
way, did not have much of.
I still think we lack
a strong ecosystem
but now, we have a
greatly changed ecosystem
for the art of our time
and the ideas of our time.
But what I thought
about most was, OK, now
we're going to build
this new museum
and raise all this money.
What resources does this
allow us to put in service
to our community?
In addition to art,
artists, and ideas,
which are our bread and
butter, the two things
that I thought the most about
were access to the waterfront,
because access to
the Boston Harbor
was pretty nonexistent
in a programmed way,
in a beautiful way.
Similarly to what you're
describing in Rio.
You need to be wealthy to
have a waterfront apartment.
At the time we were
building the museum,
there was a tremendous need for
programming in the after school
hours between 2:00 and
7:00 for our teams,
where we knew that in Boston,
our Boston teams needed
more support, more activity.
They needed a
community to be part
of their education writ large.
That the true education
of our young people
requires our community-based
institutions, which
I consider a museum to be one.
So we invested in teens.
We have the best ones.
For those of us who
have raised teens,
you know how they
keep you young.
But more than that,
they keep you honest.
When we think about
the issues of our city,
even though now we're
challenged by being, again,
in a privatized and
wealthy enclave,
because that's what the
ICA has partly engendered
in the value of that real estate
and that's a troubling thing
I'd love to talk about.
The gentrification that
is accompanying so much
of the museum construction.
But we are not removed
from our young people.
Our young people
keep us connected.
However much we talk about the
work we do teaching our teens,
I think the greater truth
is that they have changed us
more than we have changed them.
That's my initial response.
Thank you.
It's great to be here.
David and I are at the beginning
of what Charles and Jill are
at the other end of, right?
I have to defend my decision
for the lack of images.
It really is because we are
at the very, very, very, very
beginning of designing what will
be the Studio Museum in Harlem.
In many ways, this panel
is about the future
of the museum but our--
Can we get the slide of the
future Studio Museum in Harlem?
Look at what we have.
Oh, you have your--
Well, we have--
Yeah, OK.
In thinking about the
future of the Studio Museum,
it really comes from
the issues of our past.
And that is, that
the Studio Museum
was founded in 1968 on a
real question and a belief.
A question about whether
museums could and would
ever change to embrace
the work of Black artists.
But a real belief in the power
of the work of Black artists.
Therefore, the need for a museum
that would be devoted to them.
In a rented loft space in Harlem
on 5th Avenue, 125th Street,
we were founded but with no
idea of what our future would
be, other than those
very deep founding ideals
about the necessity for a
cultural institution that
would operate deeply
in the community,
but also very broadly
in the world around
and about Black artists.
We acquired the building
that we are currently in 1979
and moved in 1981.
But it was
100-year-old building,
built in 1914 as a bank.
And had been a bank on 125th
Street for many, many years
but vacant for the 10 years
before we moved into it.
When thinking about our
future, it became very clear
there was a necessity
in our future
just to think about the
very practical issue that
came from living in as an arts
institution and a building that
had been beautifully adapted.
Amazing example
of adaptive reuse
by the pioneering
architect Max Bond,
who was a founder of
the Museum and really
worked deeply to create out
of that space, a space that
would encompass our studio
program, our collection,
and our exhibition programs.
Fast forward into 2003, '04,
'05, '06, beginning to imagine
what the museum was and what
Harlem was becoming and looking
towards our 50th anniversary,
it became clear we had to think
about this differently.
In many ways, the beginning
of the conversation
that has led to what you
have seen with David and I
was a brief that
was very practical
because we needed everything
in a very practical way.
Studio Museum has no doors
that are over 10 feet high.
Every work of art
bigger than that gets
unrolled out on 125th Street.
We don't have a loading dock.
I could go on for all of the
things that we did not have.
But really, in some
ways, because I'm
a curator who now is
a museum director,
the brief started as
an exhibition query.
What I said to
David and his team
is that I wanted a
building that knowing
what our founding mission
was and was about.
In a way, I would say the
founders of the Studio Museum
put our mission into our name.
Studio Museum Harlem.
The three critical
factors of what we are.
I said I wanted also
in this new building
to evidence the three
experiences of Harlem
that I thought were
incredibly important.
The first was the
experience of the street
and understanding the
street life of Harlem
as being the way in which
Harlem understands itself.
I wanted the experience
of the stage and the idea
that for many the
idea of Black culture
comes through the
performing arts.
But in Harlem, that has
been known from the Harlem
Renaissance to the present
through the great performing
arts culture that
plays out formally
and informally through
the neighborhood.
Then finally, I wanted the
experience of the sanctuary.
Important, critical experience.
Both the physical space of the
sanctuary as the civic space,
as a spiritual space, as a
political space, but also
the way in which
those spaces in Harlem
have punctuated
the neighborhood.
Creating harbors and
houses of all faiths.
David responded
to that by adding
one more, which was the
stoop, which in many ways
brought it all together.
Because with the
stoop, what David did
is spoke very beautifully
about this space in Harlem
that connects the public
space and the private space.
This interstitial space.
Coming out of your
house to be on the stoop
or coming off the street.
The way in which the stoop
was a gathering place.
That's really what
we've been working with.
Putting those ideas--
The street, the stage, the
sanctuary, and the stoop.
--up against the loading
dock, some good HVAC--
[LAUGHTER]
--some flexible walls, a little
pour of concrete on the floor.
See, this is now
a design meeting.
Pour of concrete on the floors.
But putting that
together to create what
would be in a neighborhood
that is radically changing.
Gentrification is
one part of it.
But it's also changing in
its architectural frame.
What David, he spoke about this
beautifully and has so much,
puncturing what is becoming
a commercial architecture
of the neighborhood
of 125th Street
with what will be this building,
this cultural anchor, one
block west of the Apollo.
Sitting, as we think,
looking across at each other,
really evidencing
for the neighborhood,
the immediate
community, the idea
of what it means to
have a cultural anchor
in the neighborhood.
We are in schematic design
and thinking about making
all of these things real.
Are you laughing?
No, we're like--
Reminiscing.
We're reminiscing?
Yeah, we're nostalgic
for something
but It's not schematic design--
Storage.
--at this point.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
But we are in this process.
What I'll say about
the process is
it's been made amazing
for us as an institution
because David has responded so
profoundly and so powerfully
not just to our needs
but to our aspirations.
That's what has made it, even
in this beginning moment, such
an amazing process where we can
see what the Studio Museum will
be, which in so many ways,
is what our founders imagined
in 1968.
They really saw that
possibility and David has made
it manifest in this design.
I come to this as the
artist and as someone
who is offered to
have exhibitions
or to speak in museums,
engage the collection,
do part of educational programs
of different institutions.
I would say over the course
of my career, that's varied,
even in terms of the reception
of my work in [INAUDIBLE],, had
lectures maybe in the
'80s where there were bomb
threats for just
having an artist who's
doing a certain kind of work.
Lecture at a hall and
having to talk to security
about how I proceed.
My experience goes, in terms
of exhibiting in the United
States, quite broadly.
But what I've come to--
It's not so much
about the buildings.
I mean, yes, we can
all point to Bilbao
and the Guggenheim as this
franchise, that just gets
put out through
different governments
and built in any kind of
fashion that becomes necessary.
But I think the commitment,
as you speak of United States
and as some of the projects
in Rivington Place that David
talks about, in terms of
mandate of knowing where you are
and your relationship to a
community and having a mandate
and how that gets served.
Yes, I think over the past,
I've been doing art for a while
but I would say, in my
career in the past 20 years,
I've seen a lot of
commitment really to,
how does a museum
shift, change, expand,
and still have the
money to do programming?
To still engage its community?
Community really meaning
young people, families, people
who may not be able to afford.
How do you get them
into the building?
How do you broaden the economic
and racial and ethnic scope
of who your audience
is or who you
think your audience could be?
And how that should shift
and change and broaden.
On the other side, which doesn't
in terms of the art world,
and only maybe in this past year
or so getting a little bit more
discussed, is inside the museum.
As an artist,
again, my experience
in terms of curatorial
staff, educational staff,
the development department,
if I, as an artist,
walk into any of
these rooms that
are behind the scenes, many of
the times everyone is white.
Not all the time and
not in all institutions
but in many major institutions
throughout the country.
While we have this idea
of place and where we are
and how we're serving this
other community that's outside
or needs to be
brought in, the mirror
also has to be turned around
to the interior of construction
of who is working in the
museum and what level
and how diverse and broad
and rich is that experience.
Not to say that the
diversity of one's staff
points to expertise because the
relationship to what people do
and what their focus is
does not necessarily have
to do with their ethnicity.
But this broad sense
of, why does it always
end up so homogeneously?
And the stakes for
keeping it homogeneously
is a big question to me.
While there are all these
different programs--
To be honest, in watching
Thelma at the Studio Museum
and the mandate of the Studio
Museum, which has been amazing,
and watching not
only the development
of the career of artists and
their work through the studio
program, but also developing
the careers of young curators.
Where they get the opportunity
straight out of graduate school
to act as curators,
who get immediately
hired away by other
large institutions.
But that's also
part of the point.
But it seems like no
one else can find a way
to find those graduate
students who are working
and that there is a broad
collection of people.
In that way, that's my
other hope for the future.
That in terms of not only
the way that the mandate
of the museum in terms
of how they're built
and how they want to outreach,
but also their inclusiveness
inside as well.
Thank you.
Thank you all very
much for the responses,
comments, speculations.
We'll have many, many
threads to pull, I think,
at this point in
terms of conversation.
We'll just try to proceed
with a discussion,
leaving a little bit of time
at the end for some questions
from the audience as well.
What I like to do, I
think just to prompt
some initial elaborations
from each of you
is to ask you to develop a
bit the issue of audience
that has come up in the
different presentations.
But I want to frame
that in a particular way
to try to associate
it with certain terms
that I've heard you
using respectively.
I'd like to frame the
question of audience
around the need for the museum
or the desire for the museum
to calibrate wonder
and familiarity.
I think wonder is a
word I put forward to,
in part, because it's
the source of the museum.
The cabinet of wonders
right from centuries ago
and from these initial
moments of seeing
the museum as a place apart,
a place of seeing the unknown,
seeing the unimaginable,
and so forth.
That it has continued
as a space of wonder
that we now might
use other words,
like spectacle,
which has come up.
Then on the other side of this,
the other term, familiarity.
I put forward because
I think we also
have a sense that over
the past century or so,
two things have happened
with regard to museum.
One of which is simply
that museums have
become more familiar spaces.
And such that we can now have
international art tourism
that we know the
behaviors of movement
in a museum as a
sort of expectation.
That's one side of it.
But I think more
importantly, you said it
in several different points,
you've raised the need
for the museum to be
a space of familiarity
for its local audience.
A space that solicits the
engagement of its community,
be a space of belonging.
I put forward these
two terms because it
seems to me that they're not
immediately reconcilable.
To produce wonder, to
produce the sense of a place
apart and a specialness,
seems, in some ways,
to work against the
desire to produce
a space that is recognizable.
A space that an
audience will recognize
that it has an entitlement
to, that it belongs there,
that it's allowed to enter into,
and that it can participate
in as part of a local
community or as part
of a specific
constituency group.
I put forward those two terms.
I think they attach to
terms that you've used
and so I won't force them
on you as a vocabulary.
But I'm wondering how you,
both in terms of architecture,
in terms of curation, but also
in terms of our practice, where
there is a similarly a
desire to produce wonder
but at the same time to
cultivate an audience's sense
of expectation and familiarity.
How do you think about the
calibration of those two
dimensions in the museum?
I think that's the
perfect question
to start the conversation.
Because in a way,
I think that there
is the paradox about the
discourse of what the museum is
and the role of the museum.
From what you posit, this idea
that the wonder [INAUDIBLE],,
the box of wonder, which
is made in a palace
traditionally within a
community, which is completely
hierarchically stratified,
or the elite and the surf,
as it were, was about
a way to try and start
creating moments of
inspiring that lower class to
aspire to more.
To create a civic, a
flattening of information.
I think what you
get is that notion
of the palace and
the wonder building
works when the city is
at a certain formation.
When you get to
this condition where
you have the development of
a middle class, a flattening
of that information, the way
in which the city has grown
to the position that it
is, and at the beginning
of the 21st century, the
explosion of urbanism,
which changes the paradigm
of what the city is
and the relationship
that we have to spectacle
and the wonder of
the building, you
get this hyper condition,
which I think Bilbao sums up,
which is to create
this hyper palace.
Almost entertaining
visual attractor
to still keep the interest.
Then I think that you have
something that's now, I think,
becoming interesting, which
is this notion of trying
to start to create
threads and systems which
speak to a way of thinking about
how art practice is happening.
Because our practice is
no longer necessarily
about wonder and spectacle.
But is about talking about
issues about the society
that we live in,
the way in which we
perceive issues, the way
in which we're consuming
information, the way in which
the information is representing
us and reflected out.
You have this shift
that I think is now
different to that
old 17th century
notion of what the edification,
education, of the population
is.
I think that that
is the challenge
right now because there is
a tendency in architecture
to think that it's
always about the wonder.
I think that there is
another notion, which
is to accept that the
wonder has happened
and that there's a broader
flattening of the information
and a deeper
interaction that's now,
I think, the real agenda
for me in the 21st century.
The real agenda, I
say that as an issue
because I think that
the densification
of our urban
environments creates
a new relationship where
this idea is now very, very
important.
The way in which cities change
has radically changed that we--
The palace is no longer the only
building that's always there.
The temporality of the effects
in the city have shifted.
Are we now talking about
continually chasing that speed?
Or are we talking
about different modes
of working, which start to
engage in a different way?
The practice, which
I think has already
shifted in the makers of or the
producers of the content that
are in those buildings.
I also think in some
ways, when we're
talking about the life and
the mission of the museum,
this idea of wonder
and the familiar
are somewhat a false dichotomy.
Because it's not a question--
The wonder is what exists within
the art and the art experience.
That can still be
there and still
the institution,
however, through access,
can offer that opportunity.
Really, it's not so
much that some of us
are trying to make our
institutions familiar.
We are trying to
make them accessible.
That accessibility
is about how people
understand the institution.
That's all kinds of people.
How they understand
the institution
and what they understand
the experience to be.
That really gets that some
of those much more practical
issues as well.
Now certainly, it's something
we've thought about,
the architecture itself.
How does the building speak?
What is the experience of this
building versus the other kinds
of experiences that people
have in architecture,
say, in my local community?
That's why bringing in
those ideas of those spaces
was important.
But I do think that when we're
thinking about a 21st century
museum, we have to
reject some notions
of this traditional idea of what
a museum was in order for us
to really open out
to what a museum is.
I think that's what--
Charles referred to these
statistics the Broad has.
They've been shared
with many of us
by their director, Joanne
Heyler, and they're incredible.
It's incredible
what's going on there
in terms of, not just
these demographics he
spoke but the age.
The median age there is
30 years younger, at least
than most other museums.
The amount of time
people are deciding
to go in advance, that
goes against this idea
that millennials don't
make any decisions.
[LAUGHTER]
Like the moment they're
going, all of that.
Even the way in which
one enters the building
and begins to engage
with the ticket takers
and into the galleries.
All are about a different
way of creating.
Still, the art being
the space of wonder.
But how we enter the institution
and live in the institution
is super different.
Thelma, you and I were
at a conference in La
where we heard a
lecture and we heard
about the great artist,
Anna Deavere Smith,
using the term
"radical welcome,"
which comes from
the church movement,
to talk about what
cultural organizations need
to do to change this approach.
And what does it mean to
embody that architecturally,
programmatically,
experientially?
I mean, I know that's
what we're trying
to embody and to embrace.
It requires change.
It isn't automatic.
It's work.
The one thing that
I might challenge,
though, is I don't
think most people are
familiar with the
museum experience.
I challenge that.
I think most people are not
familiar with the museum
experience.
I think, actually,
a lot of our work
is about breaking down
that across class and race
and geography.
Reminding ourselves
that we have--
There's a really
big world out there
that we're just
scratching the surface at.
We've got lots and lots of
work to do in the future.
I'll just add that
little something.
I think every museum
experience has
to be filled with
wonder even if it is
something that feels familiar.
I think that there's
always a balance.
I agree with Thelma,
there's always wonder.
I mean, I look at the Picasso
show that was put on at MoMA
and you knew most
of those pieces.
They were comforting in
that you recognized them.
You could walk into a
room and say, oh wow.
Then simply the way that they
were paired with other pieces
and the way they were shown--
Wonder.
Beauty.
I think the institutions, and I
think Jill was saying this too.
The institution is what
needs to feel familiar.
The thing that you feel like
it's your family, you love it.
I'll just leave by
saying, and we've
got to get to technology today
and it goes to the millennials.
How I think we all
are concerned perhaps
that attention spans
are very little
and that we're so
image-driven and media centric
that we live on spectacle.
We have to have the
wonder or whatever.
I think that the
culture is changing.
I think it's imperative that
we follow suit in the way
that we think of museums.
Or we offer something else.
I think that that
could be a model.
I'd like to add, I
think, with respect
to that in terms of
technology and young people
and having a teenager
and being aware
of all these
collectives online that
are run by teenagers
and people like maybe--
19 is really old.
Those are the older
founders and members.
But that their engagement
of museums are all online.
Their mission is really to
create this space online
where they share information
that they get from archives
from online sites, from
other institutions,
and they can build their
own narratives about them.
They can invite
other young artists
that might be more isolated.
They're on their computer
but they don't go to museums.
They don't have this access
to the outside world.
But they build their own
narratives and their own art
historical canon about things
that they read and online
about all these
different institutions.
In some ways, I think the future
of this curatorial discourse
within the museum has to engage
young people and their ideas
about the archive and what
it represents to them now.
That becomes a conversation
between the institution and--
What happens in one
of these collectives
that I'm thinking about.
Between two founders,
one is 15 years old,
the other is 17 years old.
They were asked, when was
the first time you've met?
They go, we've never met.
We'll meet next Wednesday.
Had never met in person but
they've been working together
for two or three years.
That is part of the reality.
While place and community
is also important,
engagement of this world
is also really important.
Because they're
important voices that
are broadening the
scope to other teenagers
that don't have access
to young people, who are
leading very isolated lives.
It's an amazing thing.
But do you see that as both/and?
Not either/or.
No, both/and.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
With respect to those
developments then,
do you see the physical
institutionalization
of the museum, the
Studio Museum, the ICA,
as is also constituting a risk?
A limitation in the
sense that your--
We've opened discussion
around flexibility.
But flexibility in terms of
curatorial space and exhibition
space.
But there's another
conversation around flexibility
in terms of making
concrete the institution.
Is there any sense of, not lost
necessarily, but the finally
realizing the dream of
the founders of both
the ICA and the Studio Museum
for their museum of the future,
represents a concreteness
that produces
a certain static quality and
institution that has to be
compensated in other ways?
Clearly, you describe the way
in which the ICA has opened up
all sorts of new possibilities
not only for exhibiting
but for engaging--
Community engaging, the city
engaging space and so forth.
Do they immediately present
institutional limitations
as you confront an audience
that is going to encounter
the museum digitally?
Encounter the museum in these
very unanticipated ways?
I don't think that's
an issue as an artist.
I think that's part
of the fabric that
needs to be interwoven now as
part of what the museum does.
But also part of there--
It's their engagement.
It's an archive that
you have online.
You can go through the list
of artists and look at work.
But somehow, the
institution also
has to be responsive to that
community in some kind of way
in conversation.
Definitely, in terms
of many communities
and as I was saying, these
isolated pockets that
have no kind of
cultural structures
in different communities,
it's really important
to have a place.
I don't think we can
get to a point and say,
it doesn't matter.
All you need is
something online.
You don't really need an
institution that's in a place
that people can go to.
I think you have to have both.
I think both are
hugely important.
But it's about the
fabric in which
you think of the
mission of the museum
and the landscape of beyond
its boundary of its footprint.
That digitally and
the internet is
going to be a big part of
being responsive to a larger
world that doesn't have access
even in their own communities,
if they are even
in another state.
I mean, I think also there's a--
You can argue that almost every
building is, by default, out
of date by the time it's made.
Because in the end,
it's in the past.
Don't worry.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no.
I say that in a
very romantic way.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think that there
is something also
extremely valuable about the
concretization and the made
space.
Because I think that
that is actually also--
we are at the beginning
of a digital journey
of understanding what
that means in terms
of our spatial relationships.
But architecture has always been
the device we actually trained
civic narratives about how to
perform within those things.
The concretization creates the
ritual, which creates, for me,
the practice, which
then gets handed on
to generations about
certain ways of performing
within a civic.
Of course, there are
disruptions that are happening
when new technologies come.
But the new technologies
also create their own rituals
eventually.
The beginning seem completely
vacuous to a generation
who don't understand it
and very cognitive to one.
But very quickly,
the gaps close.
The gaps do close and then
there's another expansion.
That's actually the
pleasure of the city.
I think that that's actually--
these concretizing moments
are really important to create
the rituals and patterns
and to challenge past models but
also to physicalize new models.
I couldn't agree more.
I think your talk, how
you and Thelma are talking
about the street
and the stoop, I
think the museum parallels that
in the sense of this notion
of human friction.
That by having a certain
amount of density
and colliding people who
may be unfamiliar, come
from different places or
unexpected encounters,
that from that friction
explodes ideas we don't yet know
and people we don't
yet know and invention.
I don't like the
innovation word anymore.
[LAUGHS]
But the possibilities,
that's why
big cities have great artists
are attracted to them,
thinkers.
That human friction.
I think the museum
is the site for that,
similar to the street.
But by having
walls around it, it
has also a sense of that
you can take some risk
within the protection of walls.
I think that's an
important notion of place.
It is that, but it's also--
For us, in some ways, it's
about an institutional life.
While I do believe
some of our colleagues
are going to come to
an idea that there
is a contemporary art museum
model that does not necessarily
need physical spaces in the
way that Jill has one now
or I am going to have one.
But some of that
really has to do
with a point in
institutional life.
For us, just ahead of our
50th anniversary, architecture
also became an important
way to mark, symbolically,
the museum's permanence.
We would not be able to do
this project, for example,
if we did not own our building.
The idea of buying a
building in Harlem in 1979
would not have seemed,
to many people,
like anything that made sense
from any number of reasons.
But it was the museum's desire
to be not just a part of,
but a real catalyst
to what was going
to be seen as the possibility
of great economic development
and a new kind of urbanism that
could come to the neighborhood.
That owning the building
made that possible.
Now the ownership
of the building
is what makes it possible for
us to build a new building.
We're actually
building on our site.
Our building is coming down
and we're building directly
on the site that we have been.
It's also about this
idea of, it's not so much
that we can say that
concretizing the space
narrows us.
It actually expands us.
Because it's what
allows the permanence
that says that we
can think about how
to work in all these
very different ways.
I think that speaks
in a way just directly
to the title of the panel,
"Museum of the Future."
It's not so much what
is the specific nature
of that future space
but in 1979, there's
a condition for the museum
of the future, which
is the purchase of the
land and the provision
of this possibility
at some future time.
Then what are
thoughts on the museum
of the future in those terms?
Not the predictive,
what will it look like?
But what are the
conditions of possibility
that are really required
for institutions
to think about now?
Is there a question of scale?
It's notable, I think, that all
of the examples we're seeing
are institutions that have
very particular skies, a very
particular scale, that
actually, in a way, maps
onto the scale of a community.
As opposed to the
Metropolitan or something.
These much larger institutions
that have a different
unwieldiness in relationship to
their putative constituencies.
Not just scale but
other thoughts.
What are the conditions
of possibility
that need to be considered
for the museum of the future?
I think museums have to
be local, by definition.
I think that that's
one of the things
that they get charged by.
Is the way they
relate to the site,
it's what you're
talking about the stoop,
and how we use the ICA
and we're using Brazil.
But somehow, they also
have to be universal.
Bridging those two
things is tricky.
It's a little difficult.
The Shed, it's trying
to locate itself
in the industrial
past of New York.
It's on rail tracks that
parallel the High Line's rail
tracks.
It's using port
technology that used to,
more or less, be on the Hudson.
it's harking back
to a past in a part
of the town that has obliterated
its entire past in a way.
The Hudson Yards-- not in
Chelsea, but the Hudson Yards.
But at the same
time, it's really
trying to make a
universal space.
As art that is traveling around
more and more and artists
and curators are mobile
and international,
the neutrality that
that may demand--
I mean, I'm just going to
have this be a question.
Is it a good thing
or a bad thing?
Is column-free space a
good thing or a bad thing?
Having systems that are
the same in Manchester
as in Park Avenue Armory,
as in Culture Shed.
Does that make
these places great
because they can do everything
that's been done everywhere?
Or does it make
them uninteresting?
This would be a good
time maybe to refer
to the slide we had up there.
Because we're talking about
local and global museums.
This is what happened at the
Guggenheim Museum in New York
yesterday.
I didn't see it.
I received this by an email
by one of the people involved
in Gulf Labor, which has
been in a big dispute
with the Guggenheim over
labor practices in the design
and construction for their
new museum in the Gulf.
As well as NYU and
other institutions.
It does speak to
the incredible, I
think it's a complicated
story and I don't claim
to be deep enough into it,
but the idea of working
and where you are not--
Where you're out of your element
in a really significant way.
Having to deal
with labor, having
to deal with issues of
immigration and pay,
and to try to do this in
service of a universal museum
with a global brand.
You see that there is--
This is another way to think
about the museum of the future
in terms of the conflict
and the complexity
that I think it presents.
I couldn't agree more.
I think that the discourse
ironically about the universal,
I think actually is being
very highly questioned
by a new crop of museums.
Because if we are wanting a
world where topologies reduce
and become so reductive
that they're just repeated
around the world to tick
boxes, then the experience
of the globe
becomes really flat.
I actually think
that it's really
ironic that in a
funny sort of way,
this concentration on
the notion of place,
and it could be banal,
things that seem banal,
in the cold analysis.
But actually, deeply
charge and make
rich the experience of
that local condition
are now becoming the
sought after tropes
that actually people in
the planet are seeking.
I don't seek to go see a big
palace anymore when I travel.
I seek to go experience
a local condition
or a food or a
particularity of a place.
In a way, I think that
the modernist project has
switched its game a little bit.
It's no longer about this thing.
It's actually finding a pleasure
in a world that's unifying
and trying to create the
familiar has become special.
The pleasure and the
particular has become actually
much more heightened than
its universal spectacle.
You could argue that maybe
that's a pendulum swing.
There is a caution in
thinking about that.
But I think that what is
not to be underestimated
is the speed of construction
and urbanization, which
is happening.
We laugh at places like
Dubai for just quickly buying
the Louvre or something else.
But in a way, they are
reflecting a certain condition
that's been set up 100
years before them, which
is that somehow these
palaces would codify them
as metropolitan centers.
Now, we're having this moment
where this repetition of this.
Replicating is having
the effect is getting
a bit exhausting for us.
Where there's a fatigue with
this idea of this thing.
The irony is that this is
maybe a high conversation
but I think that actually
this conversation
will percolate down eventually.
Because there is
this moment where
there is a group, a large group
of people, who are thinking,
my God, that thing
that was in New York
only is suddenly now
in my neighborhood.
It looks roughly familiar.
This notion of the effects of
simulations in different places
does have a power of attraction.
Just a spectacle.
I think that we
shouldn't be surprised
when a spectacle lands or
when something feels special
that it attracts people.
I don't think the museum's
job is necessarily just
to attract people.
I actually think it's to
disseminate information
and to create a way in which
that knowledge is actually
given to the most as a
way of making a society.
I really think its
fundamental job
is to create a certain
cultural body, which creates
a certain society that we want.
Rather than just a place
to engage a stimulation.
That's a very different kind
of thing, I would argue.
I think that's really, for
me, the conversation that's
coming here.
I think that the museum
is actually growing up
from just trying to just
attract to becoming a much more
precise tool.
I find that fascinating.
If I could ask one
last question before we
turn it over to the audience.
It deals with
institutional critique.
We were talking about the
friction and the friction
within the museum.
I'm thinking back to
Fred Wilson's Mining
the Museum project,
where at that time,
the institution of the
museum opened itself up
to institutional critique
within it through an artist who
is displacing artifacts to
create shocking juxtapositions,
et cetera.
Now we've talked about the
museum becoming a catalyst,
becoming familiar, becoming
commodified, et cetera.
I guess the question
I have is, is there
a room for
institutional critique
now that we have
arrived 100 years after
and museums have become both
established these underdog
museums that had cultural
critique embodied
in it as an institution?
And now, what are
those opportunities
for institutional critique?
I mean, the idea that we
would be institutionalized--
[LAUGHTER]
It seems a far stretch
for me because I
feel like we are pretty
vulnerable and risk-embracing.
Maybe we would love a
little less risk sometimes,
by definition.
I don't experience it that
way, let me just say that.
I think that happens
through artists.
I think that we've got
plenty of great ones
doing that and giving them
the opportunity, the space,
I actually think we do that
through our young people who
are in the museums who bring
a critique of their own.
And through our
leadership, which
is all very challenging work.
I mean, you marked the time.
'92 is when Fred's Mining
the Museum happened.
A year later, the '93
Biennial happened.
It changed curatorial practice
and made curatorial practice
inherently
institutionally critical.
I think some of what we're
talking about here when
we talk about the future of
museums, it's happening--
One, on this level
of the architectural.
We're seeing this boom,
and I'm a part of it,
of this building of new museums.
The physical space is
changing, transforming.
But at the same time, as
Jill and I have experienced,
in our field, museum
directors and curators,
are rethinking
what our roles are.
The old model of preserve,
present, collect, interpret,
has really changed to think
about engage, enlighten,
inspire.
There are ways in
which that also
is an institutional critique.
The way in which we
all embody mission
differently in our
institutions because
at core, curatorial
practice is demanding that.
I would also say the
old model of museums
doesn't look like Thelma and me.
Right.
I was going to say, I'm just
asking those hypothetically.
We are not--
But in fact, the part
of what the change is
is who are the people
who are shaping
the field going forward?
Taking the risks and succeeding?
Bringing the thought
leadership that Thelma does.
Changing our field.
We all do it in
our different ways.
But, I mean, is absolutely
inimitable and incredibly
urgent and important.
I think we're not right
here at risk for that.
Can I just add that
I also think that
that institutional critique
that happens with artists,
and artists are the ones
who challenge that thing,
is a wonderful cycle
of the whole thing.
Just when we think
we've solved it,
artists come in
and slap up around.
Actually, you haven't
and the thing has moved.
I thank God that artists do
that because otherwise, we
would create entropies that
would be deeply problematic.
They're continually
being remade.
What is, I think, a
very unique moment right
now is that there is this birth
of these new types of museums.
I think that that is a wonderful
moment at the beginning
of the century.
On one way, we're
really forming something
which will be toppled in
maybe 50 or 60 years time,
might be 20 depending on the
speed of how things develop.
But it's amazing to
be witnessing that.
I would say that
the people who are
on our boards, who
are our partners,
are equally willing
to embrace risk.
That, too, is I think a
change that we're both
seeing and creating.
But it takes a lot of people.
I know creative time
has its little tagline
they were that says, visionary
art needs visionary funders.
But I steal that all
the time because I
think it's absolutely true.
We're each creating communities
that are working together
to make change in
our neighborhoods
and in our places.
We're going to take a couple
of questions from the audience
before we conclude, if we can.
Ticket price is a huge
barrier to accessibility.
In what way can low
or cheap tickets
be designed into the
museum of the future?
Yeah, I think the
future for most of us
is an example that, it's why
we're all looking at the Broad,
is being free.
But that takes a very
visionary funding structure.
It takes an important
endowment structure.
But I think, again, in the shift
in the way in which we think
of ourselves, who
we think we are,
who we think we're
serving, it becomes
almost impossible not
to think of making
it possible for the museum to
be free to really reach mission.
I think it hasn't happened
as radically as some of us
might hope.
Most of us have been able to
make this happen with fully
free days, for example.
The idea there is to
start with one day
and you'll get to
seven at some point.
But it is a place at which
you are exactly right.
That is one of the
number one ways
in which we can
create accessibility.
We know it works because
when we see it in action
is when we see audiences
that are broad and diverse
and are also engaged.
Because of the sense
of welcome that
comes because they have access.
I'd just like to
add, museums have
to operate with
balanced budgets.
While admission is actually
very small percentage
of what runs museums or
what gives them money,
you have to replace
it with something.
I think one of the nasty
facts about museums
these days is the
buildings get rented out.
There's strange
affiliations that
happen between
corporations and museums.
They may not all be perfect
but they're necessary.
I think we actually
have to deal with that.
Dealing with that
is something that
would allow museums to be
more accessible to a larger
percentage of the population.
Trying to think of
a second question.
Right here.
Hi, I have a question about
the idea of knowledge.
Going to a museum is always
entertaining and nice.
But about 10 years ago,
when you go to a museum,
you would have a certain
amount of knowledge,
like learning how to see
the art pieces so you
would have some
kind of knowledge
before you go to the museum.
But these days, when
you have, for example,
30 minutes at the
Louvre, what you would do
is go in, rush into the
Mona Lisa, take a selfie--
a lot of Millennials would do--
and go back out.
And my question is, as
the generations change,
the amount knowledge
they will have
before entering the
museum will be different,
so how the museum of
future should address that?
Possibly with technology
or with any other means?
No, you're right.
Because it's a great
question and I don't think
we have an answer.
But I think you are
asking the question
we're asking ourselves.
There are a few points
in your question,
however, that are
interesting and that we are
seeing in a generational shift.
As Lorna spoke
about, young people
are spending more time
engaging with art online.
They do come with a certain
image bank in their minds
when they're entering
into institutions.
Quite often, it's what brings
them into the institution.
Many of us see, for example,
the trail of social media
and the way in
which that will take
what is the image on the digital
screen into the experience
of being in a place with other
people with those works of art
and being able to discuss them.
What I don't think
we've figured out
is how that becomes
a seamless process,
between that digital experience
and the one in the museum.
And how we might shift the
experience of the museum
to really galvanize
in a better way
the ability to allow
people all the information
they want, so that they
can gain more knowledge
as they're engaging
with those works of art.
But we're all experimenting
and experimenting wildly
with some of this in
the hope that we're
getting somewhere in a change
in the way in which this
all will work.
Do we have time for one more?
OK.
I'm very fascinated in
listening to the different talks
about how a number of people
talked about the museum
as a space of performance.
In terms of performance,
for me and theater,
there are different
types of theaters.
There's the theater
of the castle, which
has the King's perspective or
the royal perspective, that
allows for the ideal
view from only one
place in the assemblage.
Versus the view of
collectivity that we
have in the Greek theater,
where the audience itself,
the assemblage of people,
is actually the show.
In listening to the talk
and the range of questions
and so forth, I see us
going back and forth
as a culture between the
castle and the collectivity.
I'm wondering,
where, in the shift,
in the 21st century shift or
perhaps in the 20th century
shift, those two
came into alignment?
The castle which
limits the collectivity
versus the Greek
theater of democracy,
which is always looking to
increase the collectivity.
Should I go?
This one seems--
Bring us home.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I think I was trying to
talk about that when we talked
about the notion of the palace.
Yes.
If you look at the
evolution of the museum,
you could argue that
modernism attempted
to blend and to upend the
notion of the panoptic view.
That was the modernist project.
Everything right through to--
I argue that
actually the Pompidou
is a very important point
more than the Guggenheim
in understanding the
evolution of museums.
Because the Pompidou creates
the largest single span,
flattest, most accessible,
plate to democratize art
that has actually been done.
It uses technology as a way
to infrastructure and support
that.
Then at that moment,
there's a pause.
I don't think much has
happened after that
and we're trying to
learn after that.
Because I think what happens
is that there's then now
the question of fatigue and
scale and relentlessness.
When does just flattening
it also have its limits?
I think that that's
also now creating
polarities where you have
the Guggenheim, which
was the broach, the object
as a specific destination
with its ornamental quality.
Then there's another discussion
about maybe a much more--
I think the rise of ICAs, which
is a contemporary condition,
and non-collecting
institutions are
a response to that relentless
large, overwhelming condition.
To create much more boutique,
much more curated, much
more experiential moments
which are targeted to empower.
There is an effort
that's happening
within architecture
and museology
to deal with this
democratization.
But I think that, actually
what you're hitting at,
which I think is very
important, is that ultimately,
art's mission is
to try and bring
that other part of our
lives into the everyday.
It's not to make it rarified
into the holy of holies
of the chapel or in
the palace of the King.
But to actually have that
as an everyday experience
for everyone because it
actually creates a richer
condition for our democracies.
[APPLAUSE]